what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we're here to watch uh bro
what's this whatever for my 19 or by 19
today coming sweaty and smelly from the
gym I'm thinking of getting one of these
bandanas made that say reject on it vote
in the comments if you think that's a
good idea I feel like it'd be like a
good excuse to not shower after the gym
and feel like I'm ready for a camera
sure that is a reject on you yeah no it
looks bad my attire is ready to go
alrighty guys well you know what to do
please go ahead leave a like that mean
the world as always you can find these
full-length Reaction watch alongs racing
with your own copy of b99 or super sexy
Rejects at our patreon page thank you to
all who have joined cover a bunch of
stuff there exclusively reaction hats
Watch Dogs
included anywho let's see what's going
on today with the show
I've been going at it for six hours he
won't say a word I'll take it from here
hope you boys brought popcorn because
I'm about to put on a show I hear you
don't like answering questions Marcos
I'm not asking
embarrassing
nope so looks like we're locked in
that's bad news for you because you're
trapped in here with a psycho beat him
with the handle has anyone tried it from
the outside Lock's broken got to call
facilities copy that no rush
we got an ETA on facilities at least 45
minutes the room firstbestos I feel like
I'm sucking on a tailpipe in here Marcos
everybody get away from there
all right
[Music]
shoot the window calm down man I'll
confess just stop freaking out I robbed
them boo and I was faking the whole
thing to break him I could have stayed
in here forever good because facilities
gonna be a couple hours we're gonna die
in here
[Laughter]
very fun game
but in my version everything is a
Transformer except cars
no way well it might be hard to do the
CGI and the biscotti but yeah I think we
could pull it off huh no look who's in
Captain Holt's office you are looking at
the second Circuit Court of Appeals
judge Laverne Holt holy [__]
age 39 Laverne kennebrew Holt
single-handedly raised two children and
still managed to become one of the first
black female federal judges holy [__]
this is unprecedented
we're gonna meet her everybody be cool
what are you up to it's jamming
come on
slap of the face okay never mind to come
into my office please oh wait uh do you
think it was a jam on there yeah I think
it was the jam on thing sabotaged it by
trying too hard The Honorable Laverne
Holt I'm very excited to meet you and
let me just say I'm a huge fan of your
early work talking about this guy right
here that was humor mother I know and I
thoroughly enjoyed it
Peralta my mother's house was burgled
and you want me to cover the case
because I'm your favorite detective of
all time also the jam on incident
favorite oh when I got home last night I
noticed that the window had been smashed
the apartment was a mess they took all
of my jewelry I assumed they entered
through the window it was her we'll stop
by later and check out the crime scene
that sounds appropriate I should be
going detective Captain your honor
detective Captain your honor hey this is
fun let's do it again your honor Captain
humor
humor I expect you to act in a
professional manner not a personal one
you're referring to the fact that I love
making everything professional people
love that around here it's about wink
finger gun
perhaps Boyle is still available no no
I'll be good I'll holster that thing
Hitchcock freeze get your hands off the
couch we finally got some money to
spruce up the break room what the break
room's perfect the way it is what have
you done Terry I'm open to any and all
suggestions let's try from a wide
variety of sources anything from Cameron
Diaz's Kitchen in the holiday to Kate
Winslow's Kitchen in the holiday is that
such a huge range good kitchens nasty
Maya style kitchen two great ideas let's
keep them coming we could get one of
those Spot the Difference arcade games
with pictures of naked ladies
tap daddy too
is this the real this is a real game I
blew a huge opportunity to work a case
with Holt's mom I mean I don't have time
for your sob story okay I blew a tire on
the way here so I have to call a tow
truck Chelsea Peretti's pregnant
I don't know how to change a tire I am
so disappointed condescending and untrue
why would I do something myself if I
could pay someone else oh yeah look Gina
don't call a tow truck okay I will teach
you how to change a tire you'll be so
happy I did yes but on one condition you
buy me lunch what phone okay no no
whatever you want fine just let me teach
you please I need to win today oh it's
very satisfying to learn how to change
the tire the alarm company said the
break-in happened around 7 30. is there
anyone who knew you'd be out the people
who were with me at wine club oh my I
just remembered Carol spitzeim's House
was broken into several months ago also
during wine club fascinating that
happening coincidentally or vanishingly
small I would say infinitesimally yes
and I would say tinally weenily
sounds like we should go undercover to
the next wine club meeting and scope it
out final question is this little
Raymond's macaroni art no that's a
macaroni infographic he made about
educational spending during the Johnson
Administration
I know you're having fun but enough is
enough with the prying personal
questions you're annoying my mother are
you blind we're vibing like crazy I
assure you my mother's not a vibrator
definitely not what that's yours
I think she and I make a wonderful pair
and we're already becoming friends now
that is humor is everything all right
we're all done in here your honor don't
be so formal call me Laverne okay
Laverne yeah holds you dumbass I ship
them screw Amy dying to get a little
tipsy at wine club and just dish with my
new BFF Laverne my mother doesn't Dish
as one of her better qualities you know
who else she told to call her Laverne
with a substitute mailman hello
substitute man I'm Tyrone beverton a
Bordeaux Enthusiast too sometimes
dabbles in the burgundies if fours oh my
these are two prospective members Tyrone
and tank Tyrone likes bordeaux's and
tank is beloved by mothers I live at 100
Charming Avenue and Tyrone here is at
328 2nd Street right next to a you burnt
pizza great enjoy your tasting it's
embarrassing 100 at Charming Avenue it's
a real place I looked it up specifically
to make you mad okay I'm gonna go find
and catch our purp love you bye but that
Google search spiked today this aired we
should
poster I'm on Terry shoulder screwing
the light bulb and Rosa stands by a
ladder looking up at us like buddy what
did I get myself into I love that idea
sign me up property Precinct this place
looks amazing it looks like a Swedish
airport everyone's gonna love it
everyone I talk to checked out check out
this guy at the bar he's fertibly
looking at my mother see what he has to
say for himself alertably furtively
anyway uh we're no members George
Henderson I'm fairly new to the club as
well how'd you hear buddy
I didn't didn't hear about it that seems
rather odd
does it I'm sorry I I gotta leave now
awkward Mr George I'm getting hints of
guilty with undertones of lying oh yeah
and a strong bouquet of up to no good
boom and voila tire change what's up
with her for it there's nothing more
empowering than getting a condescending
colleague to do a menial task I'm
talking about how you just changed my
tire while I sat here watching a 20
minute video of a monkey getting its
haircut you laughed at my joke did I oh
the Jack of all trades silly monkey oh
there's a monkey
come back to being your close personal
friend Jake okay George kenderson we ran
his name through the system he got a
parking ticket outside your apartment
last week we think he was casing your
place son of a [__] I am shocked right
now and I am enraged we are shocked and
enraged I'll get the car stay with my
mother I've never seen her this shocked
before come on to him Jake I need to
tell you something in confidence it's
happening
George Henderson did not rob me he was
not casing lover how do you know he was
with me that night doing what oh doing
you
George and I have been in a relationship
for two years Raymond doesn't know
please don't tell him I'm asking you as
a friend oh
here's a dish that car belongs to our
lead suspect George kenderson I remember
saying it can't be Henderson remember we
made up that little song understands not
the one back to the drawing board
very groovy I feel like I know this
street I know try to piece it together
let's bring him in Peralta
[Music]
the lighting's so blue
just tell them
nope no he didn't he's your mother's
lover he's lovering your mother
he's a mother lover she told me last
night they've been together for two
years
so are you upset or just processing or
just stopping in the middle of nowhere
he's gonna beat up the guy behind him oh
my God he's going through something oh
my now you say sex no point King no
drinking that's too similar to blinking
I'm looking for the words smashing of
stuffs entanglement
it's an entanglement well let's go talk
about the case the arrest for
obstruction of justice what I know
you're sleeping with George as you
withheld information from this detective
about an ongoing police investigation
maybe we should all just take a deep
breath and consider not arresting our
moms you're an unarrested mother and why
don't you handle the case on your own
good day
why is nobody breaking in a new break
room I don't like it turd it's the worst
it's unusable you guys don't even like
it yes we do really you like those new
stools huh Charles
yeah I don't like it yeah a place with
so many stains that the new ones just
Blended in where the couch cushions were
so worn down they comforted all butts
large or small flat or juicy juicy juicy
and new amateurs flushed it down the
toilet skir plash was that supposed to
be a flushing sound skirt plash
oh
I knew a truck carrying Khloe Kardashian
jeans didn't overturn in a parking
garage but I've overshot the pregnant
thing I've been trying to figure it out
this whole time
Beyond
not at all on the way to math Camp a
little sad our tire blew out she said I
should never be dependent on anyone for
anything so we're not going to leave
here until you learn how to fix this yes
power play and very moving speech thank
you one little thing though it's not a
car that's my car same makes same model
but you just slashed a random stranger's
Tire oopsie
that's a crime there was an attempted
break-in at 100 Charming Avenue the
point is the only person who heard me
use that address was Daniela Andrade a
mailing list lady from the wine club
[__] to her husband Tommy hi Tommy and
he would break into the houses while the
occupants were out sipping Vino okay
it's closed great so you want to call
your mother you can tell Laverne the
whole story
[Music]
no
to get yourself into
I don't talk about this a lot but I
actually have had a difficult
relationship with one of my parents yeah
I said father you talk about it
obsessively
we're not open like that really because
you're open with me only because you
asked me Annoying intrusive personal
questions all the time exactly you want
me to just say Cowabunga mom yes yes we
are not
Cowabunga people
dismissed embrace the Bunga I am so
sorry about your tire just
I will pay for the damage wait what's
happening my tire is fine it is Gina
because this is all part of my prank
show fake Tire slashers
and you have one
and a dime yes
sign the assign the release form I
replaced that please
one of my tires you changed the tire you
were listening to me not at all I
watched a video online on how to do it
it was really empowering right
especially for your first time oh no I
had a bunch of practice I actually used
your car for that
hahaha
County this is a win
okay you're right about the break room
nobody liked it and it wasn't
functioning no Doyle so we tried to put
everything back the way it was we want
your seal of approval oh we'll be the
judge of that ask me the seal wait a
minute you Liars what's that nice couch
doing here the old couch didn't make it
the second of sunlight hit it to turn to
dust but I guess we'll just have to make
do we'll make do all over it oh
hells yeah we will
break that break it in
should we wake them nah let them sleep
they earned it earned it you guys have
wasted so much time a few others we've
already recovered a number of your items
first Raymond he's attending to some
urgent business that's a stone cold lie
Raymond Cowabunga mother
ha
handle's still broken off uh just
pretend I'm not here I'll close my eyes
we're not very good at talking about
personal matters I'd categorize that as
an understatement humor yes to alleviate
some of the tension it worked
my personal life was very sad I didn't
talk to you about it because I wanted
you to think I was strong
and I wanted you to think the same with
me
I think it's time we let each other off
the hook from now on I'm going to be 15
more forthcoming on personal details and
five percent more physically
affectionate
I love you
I love you too ah such a beautiful
moment are you guys hugging it feels
like a hugging moment
[Applause]
[Laughter]
oh man
oh man time to break down the psychology
of these characters yes of course
well it's nice actually seeing where
Raymond comes from and where his
upbringing
it's really like we never met the dad
but to see the mom get a sense of his
feminine side
really is the thing that allowed him to
be empowered in a very masculine way
is that ironic would one presume that
it might be something that led him to
identify as a homosexual is that too
much reading into it maybe a man is just
born game we should just accept that or
maybe it is because he was raised by a
strong woman
but why why would a strong woman be the
thing that draws a man to be drawn to
another man it's the it's those cooties
man they get into yourselves
psychological cooties yeah as Freud put
it yeah you become
Freud would say a subconscious behaviors
they take root in your psyche and they
make you effeminate
seeing how you know that Mom is someone
who's exactly his personality like he
adopted her personality through and
through right down to the finest details
of respect
for each other I thought that was great
and endearing and you also get to see a
tad bit of her softer side too as the
episode progresses
I liked it I liked it a lot I thought it
was very endearing and touching
and now
on to the crew oh she decided to waste
an entire day
days it seems like taxes yeah I think
this is a commentary on how the police
do not like to do their jobs that's true
they like to drink coffee and eat donuts
waste our dollars in order to just be
what do they need a nicer break room for
what do they need the feng shui for it's
a way of procrastination you see if you
look at these characters especially like
Boyle and Terry and Rosa
they have the hardest time dealing with
reality and they use this as an excuse
to escape distract themselves
procrastination is it a fierce success
fear of failure who the hell knows what
it is
but it's something there there's
something there to unpack and hopefully
by season eight we know oh yeah yeah
well and I mean you know you've got two
you know heroic figures like Scully and
Hitchcock who are trying to keep
everybody's work on track you know
realizing the problem before it even
begins we don't need all this opulence
this grossly Posh and uh and and
luxuriated break room like it's just
yeah it's it's an insult it's a slap in
the face to the citizens of New York as
well as to the Fine men and women of the
NYPD and I'm glad that they took a stand
for it and they really you know did
their part across the entire episode
even breaking in the new couch as is uh
you know customary in situations such as
these you know this even they they Rose
above the petty to honor that ritual you
know it's a big sign of character growth
and character strength
when was Brooklyn Nine-Nine season four
filmed
ended May 2017 she had a baby in 2017.
okay Chelsea Peretti might have been
pregnant she might have been at the
start of being pregnant or somewhere
along the line
I can definitely dress in her baggy or
these past couple episodes
although they didn't go full on there
was one shot where I was like oh yeah
we're gonna have her at the desk this
whole time but no yeah no just big coat
big coat seems to be trapped as a man
that is
until you learn how to change a tire try
to guess gas guess if a woman's pregnant
you end up just insulting their weight
yeah it's almost never good to guess if
anyone's pregnant
but then what do you talk about when
you're right
I mean I think it's I think it's uh it's
just the way the the every sitcom has a
way of trying to mask when someone's
pregnant
characters you're unusually wearing bad
gear clothes than usual is the method
framing people from the belly button up
and now on to
forgot her name
oh Melissa oh no Amy Amy remember the
actors yes so that's enough
if you noticed
both of these storylines dealt
with strong mothers influencing them did
you pick up on such a thing are you
sophisticated enough
to have picked up on such thematic
relevance as to why the comedy
sung so high
it's because
of one word everyone
Nuance yes
certainly yeah
[Music]
layers upon layers like Chelsea Peretti
trying to mask that she's pregnant
super layered up
or she was just cold
or yeah maybe she put on a little bit
away I don't know what it is
no there's everything the the thing that
they teach you about film criticism is
that every choice you see on screen is
deliberate I saw an interesting tweet
today
I saw a tweet to everyone oh it said yes
the disparaging differences between
critics and audience scores the word
disparaging wasn't used but I threw it
in there for dramatic respect but the
disparaging differences between critics
and audience scores
should be expected
obvious
why because critics
they go in with high standards
that's why they're critics huh
you wouldn't expect a food critic to go
to McDonald's and give it five stars
would you
if they walked out giving it five stars
be a little sus wouldn't it yeah
see what I mean enjoy your McDonald's
and let the critics do their things what
that person said they said enjoy your
McDonald's okay I think I've seen this
quote tweeting Mario
the same thing the critic and audience
score ratio heard round the world it's
the same thing yeah
200 million dollar McDonald's burger
that's what that was that's right mass
per day yes it appeals to the masses man
it's it's serving its purpose it's good
enough to get to everybody and why am I
bringing up
criticism oh are you about to have one
frankly I don't remember oh good okay I
got so caught up
and trying to remember what that tweet
said that I don't even know why I
originally brought it up was it about
Amy and uh and Gina
no okay cool because I have no
criticisms towards what happened there
sure have you ever changed the tire of
course not John it's pretty fun do I
look like a woman sure yeah I mean
there's a reason they had Amy do that
this episode I have been taught many
times how to change a tire
but the person's always showing me I'm a
Hands-On learner sure Hands-On that's
why I liked what they did with Gina
experience is the way you learn
some people might learn
by actually being told the manual
instructions you go tell me what the
rules are before we play this little
board game you got some people go let's
just play around and then I'll learn how
it goes
I'm that kind of guy and I bet most of
you are too and that's what we learned
about Gina today
and of course with Amy trying Jesus
if you look at who Amy is
to this day
she is just trying to satisfy her
parents
that is her whole journey that might be
the most honest assessment I have made
this entire discussion but everything
that she does boils down not to boil but
it boils down
to one thing and that is everyone in
some way is her trying to satisfy Mom
and Dad Jimmy Smiths
I mean look at her relationship with
everyone in this show even right down to
why she felt like she needed to instill
a sense of Independence yes inside
of pregnant or slightly overweight
Chelsea Perez
or maybe just average wages average
weight or she was thinner and then she
put on a little bit but that doesn't
mean she's overweight it's just a normal
amount
women don't need to be ridiculously
skinny unless you're the lead actress
sure but women don't need to be
ridiculous or the main supporting
actress
or you know a couple of the other very
prominent supporting characters
I think that's that's a solid assessment
though no matter who she's with she is
trying to prove herself
even if that's sometimes Petty even if
it's sometimes condescending or even in
this case if it's enriching and helpful
it's still a hunt for approval
and if you look at all these characters
that's really the psyche of the writers
sure yeah you write what you know the
writers are constantly exploring our
characters through away
of not being able to have satisfied
their parents do you notice that as a
Common Thread throughout Brooklyn
Nine-Nine oh Greg I thought you were
just sarcastic oh oh Greg I thought this
was just some joke this is just bemuse
yourself throughout this entire
discussion negative sarcasm negative
Trojan Horse sarcasm is the coward's LIE
John don't forget it oh it's live it's
perfect perfect canonical quote pool I'm
gonna get that tattooed as well along
with Cowabunga mother
that
is every one of these characters
yeah we even even write down to Jake
trying to befriend Holt's mom as a way
of filling his own void and thus also in
the process referencing his own song in
a meadow way thus trying to gain the
approval of Andy samberg's own parents
in real life over extending and
overachieving in the text of the show
it's a Common Thread throughout all
these characters
have we met Rose's parents it's been a
lot of efforts I feel like we've maybe
once seen maybe one of them about her
going to ballet yeah
I feel like we've heard a thing or two
at very least but I'm trying to like
I wasn't anybody famous who played her
dad was there
wasn't like Edward James Olmos or
something was it
been Edward Norton sure he's old enough
remember he played it very condescending
you know very big departure from what he
normally does yeah and with that crazy
accent he put on he's normally so nice
yeah yeah always never belittles
well-adjusted characters and in real
life always being you know like a kind
and well-adjusted pretty much known that
you know on set and
all around he's a very nice guy yeah yes
never very courteous never feels like he
thinks he's above you no no Edward
Norton why why would he have any
possible reason to think that
um but yeah guys
what did you think about this episode
what deeper Roots did you discover who
would you learn something about yourself
yeah who are you trying to please
everyone it's time to end this video
with the patreon
Brandon Brooklyn Benzie that's right
your your new nickname is Brooklyn and
uh you I mean you know you got this name
you sound kind of like a like a
detective you know like uh like a
private eye like oh you know slip that
case to Benzie he knows how to get
around the system you know but in a way
that always makes people feel good at
the end of it because no matter how
unorthodox your methods might be no
matter how Reckless you are and no
matter how many mothers you love in this
pursuit of Justice you always bring the
Justice at the end of the day you do
your civic duty you satisfy the
taxpayers uh the weight of
responsibility that comes with that type
of support and uh and yeah you I think
would be the perfect person to ascend to
some kind of you know legal status
that's where you get to tell the rest of
us what to do I trust you with that with
the weight of that uh massive Talent
Brandon Benzie so uh you know stay
righteous out there and uh you know if
you gotta you know pistol whip a few
people just to get what you need and uh
you know solve a case you know do what
you got to do but uh always keep your
pledge no matter what no matter who
you're on the take from shuffling money
too just remember who was there for you
at the start
yeah be well catch you next month
are you
consciously aware of what you're saying
when you're saying it what are you
I'm sorry I blacked out for like two
whole minutes there
Brandon Benzie
[Applause]